[Music]
are you champing at the bit for any
information about hideo kojima's death
stranding well you'll be happy to hear
that the Metal Gear Solid crater has
revealed a few more details about the
game even teasing its online mode
I'm Matt this is a GameSpot news update
and make sure to LIKE and subscribe for
more coverage of Kojima's mysterious
game humor
Kojima told the PlayStation Blog the
deaths stranding is an open-world action
game that gives players a lot of freedom
he explained how players who like to
fight will have plenty of opportunities
to do so but those who prefer to take a
different approach will be able to play
it their way as well he didn't go into
any further detail about this but he
could just mean that you can take a
stealthy approach as opposed to guns
blazing kojima reiterated that the game
is trying to be something that players
might not have seen before but it's
important to keep expectations in check
the stranding could turn out to be
something very familiar Kojima also
teased death strandings online mode
saying it's not in the same structure as
games that have a campaign mode and an
online mode that you go to after beating
the game what this means is unclear but
he added that players won't be forced to
go online we'll keep you up to date on
all the deaths trending news but if
you're interested in seeing a game that
uses the same engine check out our video
review of horizon zero dawn